India is known the world over for its IT
companies and call centers but the
country's economy has long offered much
more and it's growing international
investors are driving the growth and
alternative energies and in the
pharmaceuticals and manufacturing
industries India's economy is booming
some predict the country is even in a
position to top China's growth the
International Monetary Fund recently
raised India's growth forecast to 7.5
percent meaning it would overtake Asia's
largest economy for the first time in
years concerns of an economic standstill
seem to have vanished
instead a year before parliamentary
elections there's a great deal of
optimism among Indian businesses Prime
Minister Narendra Modi's governing party
the BJP has announced business friendly
reforms aimed at attracting further
investment finance minister arun jaitley
for instance has proposed a nationwide
goods and services tax to replace the
many individual regulations and help
reduce bureaucratic hurdles we shall
leave no stone unturned in creating a
vibrant and strong India the prevailing
economic situation presents a great
challenge part of that challenge is
modernizing the ramshackle rail and road
networks and tackling widespread poverty
many people in India lack access to
electricity food and drinking water
a third of the population of one and a
quarter billion live on less than a
dollar and 25 cents per day more than 65
million live in slums and child
mortality is high corruption and illegal
untaxed earnings are widespread
reportedly even members of parliament
are being investigated for tax evasion
the population suffers because of lack
of proper implementation of policies
laws are not followed people don't know
how to get their work done without
paying paying bribe so all round people
suffer as a result of the black economy
funding has even been cut for the
healthcare reforms promised by the
government on the other hand snow scale
projects and rural areas provide hope of
faster development biomass is providing
electricity for entire regions in the
north of the country at the same time
more than 11 billion dollars are being
spent to further modernize the
infrastructure Prime Minister Modi wants
to convince industrialized nations to
invest more Germany also plays an
important role in that respect the
Indian economy may be large and powerful
but a large part of the population has
yet to benefit from it even though the
OECD has just certified that India has
one of the best growth rates in the
region
you